Aunque solo han transcurrido un poco más
de tres meses desde que Lula asumió el
poder ha habido alguna diferencia entre
este y sus otros períodos como
presidente que ha cambiado
Bueno buenas tardes a todos precisamente
nada Y ese es el problema Lula sigue
gobernando como si fuera el gobierno del
2003 o del 2007 y el mundo ha cambiado
cuando uno analiza las encuestas de
opinión observamos que el 36% de la
gente dice que el gobierno de Lula es
peor que el inicio de bolsonaro El 15%
dice que es igual el 46% dice que es
mejor considerando que el 51.1 de los
electores votaron a favor de Lula hay
una pérdida de confianza por lo menos en
este y en primeros días respecto de
aquel que votó con aquel que se
encuentra con este gobierno desde el
punto de vista de esta mención que vos
hacías sobre los lamentables hechos del
Ocho de enero es curioso que el gobierno
nacional no propone no quiere Al
contrario está trabajando para combatir
la confección de una comisión de
política parlamentaria de investigación
que pueda delindar Quién fue el
responsable en la participación en la
financiación en la incitación de estos
hechos violentos que atentaron
precisamente contra los tres poderes y
llama la atención porque además el
gobierno de Lula colocó sigilo en las
cámaras del Palacio de plan alto es el
Palacio de Gobierno la casa de gobierno
de manera que digamos que desde lo
político arrancó con un poco de bueno de
presión por parte de sus electores con
muchas invasiones de tierra por parte
del movimiento sin tierra que en tres
meses Apenas ha invadido más cantidad de
tierras que los cuatro años del
presidente bolsonaro y con poca
participación legislativa Porque en
estos cien días no se ha presentado un
único proyecto de ley para que pueda ser
discutido en la cámara alta o la cámara
baja también hay análisis que sugieren
que los cambios que Lula desemplementar
no están ocurriendo lo suficientemente
rápido qué cree usted que está pasando
correcto de acuerdo
Lula está digamos que está gobernando
con un teléfono analógica en la era
digital Esta es la percepción que se
tiene criticando mucho al Banco Central
por un aumento en la tasa de interés o
por mantener una tasa de interés cercana
al 13.75 por ciento anual recordando que
en los dos gobiernos de Lula la tasa en
su nivel más bajo fue del 12.75 habiendo
llegado en el segundo mes del primer
mandato al 26.5% y llama la atención que
en el gobierno de Lula inicial cuando él
tenía El poder del Banco Central 26,5%
no era alta y ahora que el Banco Central
es autónomo
13.75 sí Parece ser alta el ministro
adad ha presentado lo que se denomina en
la nueva estructura fiscal que se basa
en que el gasto se vincula con la
recaudación con lo cual se especula que
haya un aumento de la carga tributaria
algo que el empresario y el agro negocio
claramente no está de acuerdo ahora que
le ha impedido a Lula gobernar como
prometió o como ha querido
yo creo que una cantidad enorme de
ministerios los ministros no se ponen de
acuerdo Andrés uno menciona una cosa ahí
se les ocurre una idea y lo lanzan como
si fuera una política de estado después
voy a dar un ejemplo con nombre y
apellido el ministro de energía silveira
manifestó que se iba a cambiar la
política de precios de petrobras
inmediatamente la dirección de la
empresa Estatal de petróleo Indicó que
eso no era correcto y el propio
presidente Lula dijo que silveira no
tenía autonomía como para decidir ese
tipo de cosas eso se observa
ministerios que han sido distribuidos
por canjes electorales de apoyo político
en la época de la elección y que
requerían que algo fuera devuelto en
función del apoyo otorgado al presidente
Lula y esto se está pagando el precio en
este momento el gobierno de Lula está
pagando